October is National Bullying Prevention
Month despite that there have been a
rash of school bullying incidents
reported in Pennsylvania Maine and
California in recent weeks some of them
have been deadly to fight the worsening
problem California's governor's just
signed three new laws aimed at
preventing bullying and suicides Carter
Evans is in Los Angeles with more on
this story so Carter what prompted this
action well the new laws come after one
Southern California school witnessed two
acts of violence and one of them leaving
a thirteen-year-old boy dead and
concerns a ten-year-old student at
another school might have died by
suicide over being bullied the question
now do these new laws go far enough the
student sucker-punched in this video
last month Diego Stoltz died of his
injuries a week later and on Monday
there was another attack at the same
school now police are investigating
whether ten-year-old Allison Wendell who
attended this Southern California
elementary school died by suicide last
weekend police hadn't seen her social
media and following leads at her school
that she might have been bullied who she
was not think that she was a sad little
girl that was in some you know horrible
depression because that wasn't the truth
rise up against bullying is a school
violence program based in Southern
California karina gonzalez is a
counselor there now you have students
that are bullied at school and then it
carries over at home because the bully
continues online the online thread is
addressed as part of three sweeping new
anti-bullying law signed by California
Governor Gavin Newsome over the past
month the safe place to learn act
requires that children in kindergarten
through sixth grade have easy access to
suicide prevention materials including
on the Internet meanwhile an amendment
of the state's Education Code is also
aimed at younger students requiring an
updated policy on suicide prevention
appropriate to the needs to those at
high risk including youngsters who are
disabled homeless or identify as gay
lesbian or transgender another law
creates a special suicide
prevention fund for taxpayer
contributions it would help fund crisis
centers that are active members of the
national suicide prevention hotline we
need parents and schools and communities
and our legislators to work together to
combat this problem it's a
responsibility of all of us to ensure
that our students go to school to learn
and not to survive the day
well nationwide about 20% of students
aged 12 to 18 say they've been bullied
in experts say because of the Internet
students are often unable to escape
their bullies and are constantly being
reach Ramat eyes Toni yeah it's a sad
reality Carter thank you very much it's
a good reminder to have a conversation
as a parent with your kids about this
predicament it's the scary part because
now it's literally the bullying is
literally coming into the home through
the computer or the phone whatever it is
yeah it sure does you know we can't
stress that enough you know when we were
little it ended at the schoolyard yeah
that's right and then you could go home
and that was sort of your sanctuary and
that is no longer the case